you're not trying to draw a psycho
pension
you're crazy
I've got a handy guide for you today my
producers have given me a healthy
smattering of companies and we will rank
them in order of most important to
boycott to least this video is sponsored
by genius Elmore from them in a minute
first let's get started first company up
on the list North Face oh yes North Face
had a fella with a big Burly mustache
dressed up like a chick with a summer of
Pride ad I
didn't believe this was actually a North
Face ad at first I thought it was just a
parody or something like that but but it
turns out that it's a real ad so this is
pretty egregious it was kind of funny
especially that they left him with the
mustache on no God please no and since I
am not a teenage white girl from the
suburbs I don't have a huge stake in the
North Face Fight so since it's the first
one let's put it right here on the table
but I would not say this is the most
urgent brand to boycott
also because is North Face even popular
anymore no uh I don't think so that
thing was it was cool when I was in
Middle School I assume it's not not that
cool anymore bro just trying to get some
Buzz next up Uber Eats ubereats has gone
gay
oh you know what I remember this
[Music]
if I'm not mistaken Uber Eats had this
whole ad this disgusting ad
about what to eat
before you engage in certain weird
activities in the Boudoir yeah it was
it's got this eggplant with like a
leather suit on oh my goodness
gracious okay that's up there certainly
ranks higher than North Face Disney oh
yeah Disney number one
[Music]
number one on the list by far so far
Disney is not quite as gross as say Uber
Eats you're not going to be s m
eggplants with Mickey Mouse but but
Disney is much more subtle and has much
wider reach and could be far more
influential in the culture so that one's
definitely tough for the list Procter
and Gamble Procter Gamble sponsors every
woke company ever like every every woke
ad that you ever saw is from Procter
Gamble PNG owns like everything so it is
very difficult to boycott PNG next up
Gillette Gillette is really woke in all
sorts of ways sex on Race on masculinity
on all of it I remember some years ago
when Gillette decided to convince young
girls to start shaving their faces so
John's been at this a long time it's one
of the reasons that Jeremy's razors
exists and is doing very very well
[Music]
you can buy my new razor instead still
far less egregious than
really all of these here I mean it's
still really bad but but less so than
the others right now head on over to
geniusell.com Knowles YT our friends
over at geniusell sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging on their knees for
a restock I've got great news just in
time for the summer it is back
geniusell's famous Dark Spot Corrector
has not won but three Cutting Edge
ingredients goes to work fast to Target
sun spots dark spots liver spots and
even old discoloration both on your face
and hands you can now enjoy your summer
sun Beach and barbecues without
embarrassing spots geniusell's most
popular package also features their
summer Essentials like the best-selling
Ultra retinol moisturizer with a
powerful retinol alternative for safe
use in the sun you will be amazed at how
quickly you will see the results or 100
of your money back guaranteed go to
geniusell.com Knowles YT right now to
get your dark spot corrector in the
geniusl most popular package that is
geniusell.com knowlesyt right now save
over seventy seven zero percent off
Geniuses most popular package all orders
will include a mystery gift while
supplies last genucel.com Knowles YT
today jnb this one really really got me
because you think okay Target yeah
they've been lived for a while okay
Disney uh fine whatever
but you think whiskey brands should hold
firm right
J and B J and B is a drinking man's
whiskey J and B I remember drinking J
and B when I was in college that was
like bottom shelf but you know pretty
good for what it is working man's drink
and then they've aired a commercial
where some Grandpa decides to become
that was really bad how do you boycott J
and B nobody even drinks jnb this is not
a particularly popular whiskey bad
whiskey bad sex and bad man I never
forget the commercial was very very
egregious but if you've got to
prioritize what companies to boycott
you'd put it low on the list is this
just not an influential company Target
yeah Target's up there Target even more
than PNG I think because it's so visible
and there's some momentum here on Target
Target's losing some some real Revenue
so if you can if you can just show
companies that there's a cost to
embracing this Zoro World rainbow then
other companies are going to be less
inclined to do it so it just as a
Prudential matter you got to go after
Target the LA Dodgers I don't know why
you would support the LA Dodgers to
begin with ever but yeah you got to
boycott them they go before PNG also
actually because also what what the LA
Dodgers are embracing is not just
indirectly evil or sort of vaguely or
Ambiguously evil the LA Dodgers are
honoring a group that exists strictly to
mock Christianity to engage in Satanic
rituals that mock Christ so the fact
that these people are permitted to walk
around in public without being shamed or
told to put on proper clothing or thrown
into you know some insane asylum is a
scandal that we should deal with
politically gotta boycott the Dodgers it
should be a Yankee fan Ford oh right
Ford because the Raptor turned I know
that was very silly yeah it's pathetic
all these companies though because
they've all bought into cross industry
International organizations that Force
this stuff on you because the asset
managers that invest in these companies
are all forcing the the rainbow upon
them welcome the rainbow Taste the
rainbow they all dance with it a little
bit and it's a it's a systemic problem
it's not just problem with the companies
with Ford
put it relatively lower on the list Bud
Light Bud Light
Disney is still the most important one
to get because they're
attacking our children
it's the most prominent company to
boycott
no I'll tell you what actually I'm going
to reverse this and reverse my near
decision Disney's number two Bud Light
is number one Bud Light is number one
because we got them ladies and gentlemen
we got him it's so targeted it's so
specific it's devastating Bud Light was
the most popular beer in America and
because they sponsored
they are now
in the doldrums they've now lost at last
count 27 billion dollars or something
like that Professor Bush but I buy money
the market cap is just completely
cratered the sales are so bad they can't
give this stuff away to their
Distributors they thought Bud Light
thought okay well weather the storm or
Mark a capital decrease and I'll bounce
back up that isn't what's happened it's
just it's gotten worse and worse and
worse and worse now it's just staying
right down there at the bottom so you've
got to keep that up you've got to
destroy Bud Light
Bud Light delenda EST to prove the point
to the other guys and then you can take
on even more important companies like
Disney like Target like the Dodgers like
PNG for sure you remember some years ago
when when the right was really hot on
cancel culture so we've got to cancel
cancel culture cancel culture's terrible
you might recall I had a little bit of a
different view I said hey hey actually
cancel culture is good it can be good
this version of it's bad where you get
canceled for being normal and saying
true things but we should cancel
organizations and people for
unrepentantly saying things that are
false and evil and wicked that's called
standards that's called Norms that's
called taboos I wrote a book about it
called speechless controlling words
controlling Minds definitely worth
checking out yeah we need to cancel all
of these companies we absolutely should
boycott them we should punish them for
the substance of their views that they
are advocating because the things
they're advocating are evil and not
conducive to the flourishing of our
society so we should cancel them and
punish them certainly using our wallets
but if you got to list it in order you
got to prioritize yeah
Bush Disney Target the Dodgers Procter
Gamble ubereats North Face Gillette J
and B and if you have time left over
Ford there it is that's the official
selection see you next time
hey
[Music]